last month tam mom and adam barda did a
live online event called tan talk
uh tan mom was not in the mood for
levity
in their pre-show meeting tan mom told
adam not to make her look bad
all right does that look like jerks but
don't make me look like a jerk because i
swear to god
on camera i will [ __ ] [ __ ] you how
could he screw her up
i said don't make me look stupid robin
oh hi tan mom puppet how are you hi
hello howard tam on puppet your breast
is sticking out of your
um out of your tank top your your
drop malfunction it does that from time
to time it's got a bag of its
own sorry it's got a what
it's got a mind of it
tam started out the show by apologizing
to the viewers multiple times
and here is our special guest back hello
krishna welcome
hang on everybody i just want to
apologize
and we had a delay whatever my fault
but here we are for tan talk so go ahead
adam i'm sorry well no problem patricia
you know uh
so we want to start this off by talking
about uh outdoor tanning and
kind of why you've decided to kind of
stop doing that for your own health this
year after everything that's happened
well i just want to begin by apologizing
to everyone
and she's apologizing because i think
the original tan talk
you know show supposed to happen on the
19th of june or something like that but
tan mom's hip
popped out and
my tit popped out again no no your your
hip not your tit
oh there's been a lot going on
but i have to say that alan bartow
is such a great guy to work with yeah
and really
carried me through all of that
he's been constantly saying i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i didn't know i'm
glad you
explained hi
pam mom was ready to end the broadcast
after only five minutes don't forget
people pay for this stuff
uh yeah well i shouldn't say people jd
paid to attend this thing
thank god for jaden i'm sorry i just got
distracted
and it's not
relevant for you guys but going i i'm
just
i i just can't do this video right now
yeah well i mean take a breath let's
take a breath right
we're having fun we're just talking and
i was having a great time before
before okay let's cut to the chase
yeah i mean adam barta was seeing tens
of dollars slip away right through his
fingertips as
as uh let's cut to the chase adam got
tan mom back on track with a question
about indoor tanning
tan mom said she gets very horny in a
tanning bed
hitting me pivoting it back to indoor
tanning
um what are some of the things you
recommend now you were talking to me
beforehand and you said there are some
tanning booth
must-haves why do people need water when
they go into the tanning booth because i
wouldn't think is it because you get
dehydrated or
you get dehydrated and um
you can actually get sexually frustrated
inside the tanning booth and we've
discussed it
before but you get so hot down below
in any fracture um that
you actually want to fool around or
whatever
well i was wondering if the water was
there you know to douse herself
why not just use a fire extinguisher
[Laughter]
poor jd had to watch every minute of
this special you know like could you sit
through the whole thing i
i i don't think i could stop you know i
could not turn this off
could she listen to the whole thing or
is it so bad that you couldn't really
get through it
it is a bit of a train wreck so yeah you
you want to see you like seeing train
wrecks sometimes
but yeah the stuff you know a lot of
what you didn't see is like
her showing off her little creams and
the bottles of tanning lotion or
whatever she uses
it's like all right whatever
that's jd he watched your host hi j.d
hi hello
you